en el último vídeo vimos el patrón para
la energía de ionización descendiendo en
el grupo de la tabla periódica en este
vídeo vamos a ver el patrón general al
recorrer un periodo así que estamos aquí
en el periodo 2 y el patrón general
conforme recorres el periodo hacia la
derecha es que habrá un incremento en la
energía de ionización y en este vídeo
vamos a hablar acerca de la primera
energía de ionización así que vemos el
litio el litio tiene una energía de
ionización positiva de 520 kilos por mol
y después seguimos con el berilio y ese
número aumenta y puedes ver que en
general el patrón es a incrementar así
que el carbono aumenta a partir de ahí
el nitrógeno aumenta a partir de ahí y
entonces puedes ver que estos números
están aumentando y aumentando
hay un par de excepciones a este patrón
general que podemos ver podemos ver que
el berilio al boro hay una disminución
real de la energía de ionización y
también del nitrógeno al oxígeno hay una
disminución en la energía de ionización
así que hablaremos acerca de estas
excepciones del patrón general pero
primero vamos a analizar el litio y el
berilio y ver si podemos descubrir
porque en general conforme recorremos un
periodo hay un incremento en la energía
de ionización así que echemos un vistazo
a estos diagrama de aquí abajo y
continuamos dibujando el litio y el
verín primero el litio con número
atómico de 3 así que tenemos
protones en el núcleo y la configuración
electrónica para el litio es 1 s 2 2 s 1
entonces hay dos electrones en el primer
nivel de energía en un orbitales y estos
son los dos electrones en el primer
nivel de energía que ocupan un orbitales
y en el segundo nivel de energía hay un
electrón así que pongamos un electrón
ahí
para el berilio tenemos un número
atómico de 4 tenemos 4 protones en el
núcleo y entonces para el berilio la
configuración electrónica
1 s 2 2 s 2 así que en el primer nivel
de energía tenemos nuestros 2 electrones
y en el segundo nivel de energía también
tenemos 2 electrones así que tenemos un
átomo neutro de berilio continuamos
poniendo esos 2 electrones en el segundo
nivel de energía
estos diagramas no son perfectos pero
solo van a ayudarnos a intentar entender
los conceptos simples para comprender
este patrón de aquí así que analicemos
la energía de ionización para estos dos
átomos y vamos a usar los mismos
factores de los que hablamos en el vídeo
anterior
entonces el primer factor fue la carga
nuclear vamos a continuar escribiendo
carga
nuclear
aquí y la carga nuclear desde luego se
refiere a cuántos protones tienes en tu
núcleo y entre más protones tienes mayor
será la fuerza de atracción para el
electrón externo así que si vemos el
litio con una carga de más 3 en el
núcleo eso va a atraer este electrón
externo entonces hay una carga de más 3
para el berilio con una carga de más 4
va a traer este electrón de aquí y
debido a que es más 4 pensarías que
tendría una fuerza de atracción mayor
para uno de estos electrones externos
entonces solo pensando acerca de la
carga nuclear esperaríamos que hubiera
mayor fuerza de atracción para uno de
los electrones externos en el berilio
que en el litio por lo tanto pensarías
que requeriría más energía sustraer el
electrón externo y por eso tenemos un
incremento en la energía de ionización
sólo pensando en la carga nuclear
diríamos que necesitarían que hubiera un
incremento en la energía de ionización
ahora pensemos en el blindaje o
apantallamiento electrónico el link
baje
ya miento
electrónico la idea es que los
electrones de la capa interna van a
separar a los electrones externos del
efecto del núcleo si ves el litio este
electrón de aquí va a repeler este
electrón externo y este electrón de aquí
en la derecha también va a repeler este
electrón entonces blindan ese electrón
externo de la atracción del núcleo lo
blindan de la carga positiva y si vemos
el berilio una vez más estos electrones
en la capa interna van a hacer
exactamente lo mismo van a blindar este
electrón externo de los efectos del
núcleo y así vamos a tener
aproximadamente la misma cantidad de
apantallamiento electrónico aquí ahora
para el berilio el berilio tiene un
electrón aquí que podría repeler este
electrón y probablemente contribuye un
poco a esto pero en general los
electrones de la capa interna hacen más
del blindaje o apantallamiento que este
electrón porque este electrón está en el
orbital 12 s así que estos electrones de
la capa interna
más efectos sobre el apantallamiento
entonces diremos que el apantallamiento
o blindaje es aproximadamente el mismo
para estos dos átomos y por lo tanto
realmente no hay un efecto en la energía
de ionización y después finalmente la
distancia que fue el tercer factor del
que hablamos así que la
o sea es electrón externo es para el
núcleo bueno este electrón en el litio
está en el orbital 12 s entonces en
promedio hay una cierta distancia hasta
el núcleo y este electrón del que
estamos hablando en el berilio también
está en el orbital 12 s así que en
promedio está casi a la misma distancia
del núcleo y así la distancia no tiene
mucho efecto o ningún efecto en la
energía de ionización entonces la
distancia no tiene un efecto y el
apantallamiento electrónico o el
blindaje no tiene efecto realmente en
todo lo que tenemos que pensar aquí es
en la carga nuclear continuamos y
calculemos la carga nuclear efectiva
para ambos átomos muy rápido así que
para el litio la carga nuclear efectiva
sería el número de protones eso es más 3
entonces estamos calculando la carga
nuclear efectiva
así que sería más 3 - el número de
electrones del apantallamiento
electrónico
eso sería este y aquel entonces más tres
menos 2
así que obtenemos una carga nuclear
efectiva cercana a + 1 y en realidad es
como 1.3 cuando haces un cálculo más
complicado para el berilio la carga
nuclear efectiva sería el número de
protones que aumentaría a más 4 y los
electrones del efecto de pantalla otra
vez sólo vamos a considerar estos
electrones de la capa interna para
nuestro cálculo muy simplificado de la
carga nuclear efectiva y así tendríamos
una carga nuclear efectiva cercana a
2 positivo en realidad es
aproximadamente 1.9
cuando se hace el cálculo más complicado
y así podemos ver que tenemos un
incremento en la carga nuclear efectiva
de más 1 a más 2 entonces conforme
recorres un periodo vas a incrementar la
carga nuclear efectiva y esta es la
razón que se da para el patrón de
incremento en la energía de ionización
conforme recorres un periodo en la tabla
periódica a continuación hablaremos de
las excepciones para esto lo siguiente
que vemos es que fuimos de 520 para el
litio a un aumento para el berilio por
el incremento de carga nuclear y cuando
vamos del berilio al boro vemos esta
caída verdad vamos de 900 a 800 entonces
no está siguiendo nuestro patrón general
pero vamos a ver si podemos explicarlo
así que dibujaremos una imagen del boro
aquí alguno tiene un protón más en el
núcleo entonces hay 5 protones en el
núcleo así que tenemos más 5 en un átomo
neutro el boro tendría 5 electrones
así que continuemos escribiendo la
configuración electrónica para el boro
sería 1 s 2 2 s 2 y después 2 p 1
entonces para el boro continuamos
mostrando los 2 electrones en el orbital
1 s los 2 electrones en el orbital
2 s
y después es electrón en el orbital p en
promedio un electrón en el orbital p
está un poco más alejado del núcleo así
que voy a representar este electrón aquí
mismo este sería el electrón más externo
este electrón p aquí mismo este es el
que será sustraído en términos de
ionización una vez más vamos a pensar en
nuestros tres factores verdad entonces
primero la carga nuclear bueno comparado
con el berilio que tenía un núcleo de
carga de más 4 el bueno tiene un núcleo
de carga de más 5 así que tenemos un
incremento en la carga nuclear y
podríamos pensar en este electrón como
experimentando una mayor atracción hacia
el núcleo entonces sólo pensando acerca
de la carga nuclear podríamos pensar
hay un incremento en la energía de
ionización que sigue nuestro patrón
general pero tenemos estos otros dos
factores también a considerar si
pensamos acerca del efecto de
apantallamiento electrónico sabemos que
este electrón externo este electrón en
el orbital 2p está blindado por estos
electrones internos en el 1s así que
definitivamente hay algo de efecto
pantalla por estos electrones en el
orbital 1s así pero debido a que en
promedio este electrón en el orbital p
está un poco más alejado de los
electrones aquí estos electrones están
en el orbital 12 entonces todos están en
el segundo nivel de energía pero en
promedio los electrones en el orbitales
se están un poco más cercanos al núcleo
y así que hay un poco de apantallamiento
electrónico que estará ocurriendo aquí
hay un poco de blindaje
extra para este electrón en el orbital p
y debido a este apantallamiento extra no
se sentirá tanta atracción hacia el
núcleo de esa carga nuclear incrementada
y entonces solo pensando en el efecto de
apantallamiento electrónico esto está
blindando a los electrones externos de
la atracción del núcleo por lo tanto
será más fácil sustraer ese electrón así
que el blindaje ocasiona un decremento
en la energía de ionización
finalmente la distancia
si pensamos en la distancia otra vez en
promedio este electrón externo está un
poco más alejado del núcleo que este
electrón de aquí en el berilio y debido
a que está más alejado hay menos fuerza
de atracción del núcleo y por lo tanto
toma un poco menos de energía sustraer
el electrón y solo pensando acerca de la
distancia podemos decir que hay una
disminución en la energía de ionización
entonces sumamos todos estos factores
así que pensamos en la distancia como
disminución en la energía de ionización
el efecto de pantalla de los electrones
dice disminución en la energía de
ionización estos dos resultan ser un
poco más importantes que este incremento
en la energía de ionización por el
incremento de la carga nuclear y esa es
la razón para esta caída en la energía
de ionización que desde el berilio al
boro entonces esto explica la primera
excepción para el patrón general ahora
hablemos de esta otra excepción de aquí
así que esta caída en la energía de
ionización que sería del nitrógeno al
oxígeno
entonces vamos a continuar escribiendo
las configuraciones electrónicas para el
nitrógeno y oxígeno primero vamos a
escribir la configuración para el
nitrógeno
sería 1 s 2 2 s 2 y después 2 3
vamos a continuar y hacer esto en
notación de orbitales así que tenemos el
orbital 1 s el orbital
12s y después nuestros orbitales p de
esta manera y vamos a continuar y poner
estos electrones en azul
entonces 1 s 2 se haría cargo del primer
nivel de energía y después en el segundo
nivel de energía hay 2 electrones así
que eso se hace cargo de estos
electrones de aquí y después en el
orbital p tenemos 1 2 y 3
ahora para el oxígeno escribiremos la
configuración electrónica para el
oxígeno un electrón más en el que pensar
entonces 1s 2 2 s 2 y después 2 c4 así
que cuando escribimos nuestra anotación
de orbitales
continuaré poniendo estos electrones
usaré aquí otra vez azul si pensamos
acerca de esos electrones 1s 2 eso se
encarga de estos y luego 2 s 2 y después
tenemos 24 si vamos 1 2
y después ese cuarto electrón que sólo
va a emparejar los giros ese irá en este
orbital de aquí ya que es electrón en
magenta es repelido por ese electrón en
azul esto significa que es un poco más
fácil sustraer ese electrón entonces un
poco de repulsión electrón electrón ahí
significa que es más fácil sustraer el
electrón por lo tanto requiere menos
energía sustraer ese último electrón que
lo que requeriría sustraer un electrón
de allá para el nitrógeno y esta es la
razón que normalmente ves dada para esta
disminución en la energía de ionización
del nitrógeno al oxígeno así que hemos
hablado de las dos excepciones pero otra
vez en general conforme recorres un
periodo en la tabla periódica
encontrarás un incremento en la energía
de ionización
y se debe al número mayor de protones en
el núcleo jalando el electrón externo
teniendo una fuerza de atracción mayor
para ese electrón externo y por lo tanto
haciendo más difícil sustraer ese
electrón resultando en un incremento en
la energía de ionización